[Music]
I'm grace I'm a Solutions Architect in
the cloud platform team and I'm here to
talk to you about dr so why do i why
we're talking about dr well if you're
available for the if your responsibility
if you're responsible for the
availability of your systems then you've
probably had a conversation something
like this how many of you have lived
that picture yeah quite a few of you so
so I'm now going to kind of delve into
some of the patterns and things that you
can do here so you'll be aware that
whenever you start talking about dr
there are some three-letter acronyms or
tear layers where you usually start i'd
like to start off by distinguishing
between dr and hey CheY think of hey
CheY has been for micro disasters a
single server dies at disk fails where
as dr is for a larger disaster a huge
chunk of your production systems break
down and you need to failover to a
different location
natural disasters also fall under there
so there is a relationship between the
two and in some cases particularly when
running your production workloads on GCP
you will see how HHA influences your dr
strategy for example using GCPs global
load balance that means that if a region
becomes unavailable your application
just keeps on working when we talk about
dr there are two main terms that you
need to understand first there is
recovery time objective RTO which is
directly related to how long it takes to
get your application back online it is
determined by what strategy you adopt
this value is usually defined as part of
a larger service level agreement
secondly there's recovery point
objective RPO which relates to the
amount of data at risk ultimately it
boils down to how much data can you
actually afford to lose think of it as
the last backup or checkpoint you can
roll back to this metric will vary based
on the ways the data is used for example
frequently modified user data could have
an RPO of just a few minutes as you
probably had the transaction logs that
you can roll back to
whereas a frequently modified data may
have an RPO of several hours if you need
to restore maybe last night's backup
know that this make sure disguise
describes the length of time not the
amount or quality of the data so take it
together these metrics have a roughly
asymptotic impact on your bottom line
which means that the smaller your RTO
and RPO value the more your application
would cost to run SLA in SLO are
normally normally conflated but the key
here is that the SLA is the entire
agreement agreement and specifies what
services to be provided and how its
supported times locations cost
performance penalties and
responsibilities of the parties involved
whereas SLO a specific measurable
characteristics of the SLA such as
availability throughput frequency or
quality an SLA may contain many s lows
we'll keep those definitions in mind as
we look at some of the patterns and
implementation details for the scenarios
before we explore the approaches you can
take this look let's take a quick look
at some of the production and key
features some of the products and key
features that GCP has available to help
you implement your dr strategy no matter
where your production workload is so
it's a little bit of an eye chart cloud
storage this is an object store great
for I did great for storage of backup
files cloud load balancing provides a
single globally accessible IP address to
front your back-end instances its global
so your application can have to have
instances running in Europe and the US
and your end users will be directed to
the closest set of resources jeezus CGC
instances and images the workhorse of
the cloud these are virtual machines
which you can take incremental backups
or for snapshots of that you can that
you can copy across regions you can
create custom image images with your
application you can then use them to
launch instances from manage the
instance groups working in conjunction
with gob provides a way to distribute
traffic to multiple copies of
identically configured groups of
instances
spread across multiple
zones DNA cloudiness provides a
programmatic way to manage your DNS
entries deployment manager allows you to
define your GCP environment in a set of
templates that you can then use to
create complex environments and simple
ones as well with a single command
repeatedly inconsistently equally you
can tear the environment down with a
single command network connectivity
options to transfer data to and from GCP
you need good connectivity so we provide
you with choices and how you can do this
we have a variety of connectivity
options and it's more than likely that
you will choose cloud interconnect or
direct peering to connect through to GCP
for your dr configurations so you have a
reliable link and we're not dependent on
the variances of traversing the internet
where there is no control on the hops
between your print on your own premises
and GCP I think we're in good shape now
to start exploring the approaches you
can take
so let's start with looking at dr when
your production workload is on GC p and
start seeing how we can start using this
toolbox before I go on I just want you
to draw into cloak cloud storage a bit
in a bit more detail there are a number
of storage classes the characteristics
of the specific class determines the
most appropriate use case so in the dr
scenario Nearline is a particular
interest to us Nearline reduces your
storage cost but access costs are higher
than standard it's designed for backup
type scenarios where access is at most
once a month ideal for allowing you to
do those dr stress tests while keeping
costs low beta is always a good place to
start I reckon so let's look at their
data dr techniques when your data tear
is on GC p it's safe to assume that most
of you have databases perhaps several
and likely you've considered a tiered
storage solution looking at Ted storage
in this context we're focus focusing on
using it for backups where you have the
most recent backup backup so faster
storage and then you archive off to
backups to cheaper slower storage
is a pretty common pattern so been
session this afternoon on building
hybrid confirm hybrid cloud tearing with
cloud storage for backup an archival
goes into more depth on using on this
technique here you can see an
illustration of a typical tiered storage
set up on the GCP where we use the
characteristics of cloud storage classes
to implement inevitably you need to
define some rules that describe how
objects move between the tiers
thankfully GCP makes it easy by allowing
you to script a few simple rules which
are known as lifecycle rules you could
do things like downgrade the storage
class of an object overall then two
older than 10 days say delete objects
created before March the 1st 2017 or
maybe keep only the three most recent
versions of an object in a bucket with
with versioning enabled that's only half
the story though and as on premises you
need to think about what happens when
you need to do a major upgrade to a date
to the date base server say if so then
you will need to figure out how you can
get back to a version of them on the
database server that the backups you
stored in cloud storage are compatible
with it's not as onerous as it sounds
though ok you actually have some options
about what you can do here we allow you
to create a custom image that has the
relevant version of the database
installed before we go into that I want
to talk a little about snapshots
snapshots are available across regions
which means they feel snap if you
snapshot your database you can restore
it to a different region as easy as you
can restore it to the same region as you
can take regular snapshots of your
system
this also means each time you upgrade
you can roll back to the snapshot with
the previous version if you need to as a
short-term strategy snapshots are useful
for fast recovery so back to custom
images when you launch an instance you
start from an image this this can be as
minimal as just having the default OS or
maybe haven't been fully baked and
having your application and know we're
apps installed on it decide where on the
continuum your image vis is it fully
baked or do you want
just the OS okay when choosing your
baking strategy you'll need to consider
things like boot time and manageability
fast boot times a must for auto-scaling
web servers but a database server may
not need that fast boot time thinking
about how the instance will be used in
the context of your dr requirements will
help you determine what your starting
image should look like up until now I've
discussed dr techniques applicable when
your database is deployed on a GCE
instance however GCP has arranged of
managed databases that fit a wide
variety of use cases so you you can have
you choose to have to use one of these
so you don't have to take on the
operational overhead of managing them
yourselves as you do when deploying a
database on GC instances this table
lists them together with some sample
backup meant and backup methods okay
I've been talking about data backup and
recovery but that is only half the story
you also need to consider the dr
strategy for your application or service
that uses that data the techniques i've
already discussed like snapshots and the
stand and the concepts discussed with
Rhian images are all applicable we need
to bring your application and your data
to recovery techniques together look at
the bigger picture when designing the
strategy the typical way to do this is
to think about your RTO and RPO values
and then what dr pattern you can adapt
adopt sorry to meet those values so dr
patterns are considered to be cold warm
and hot think of these as been how ready
you are to recover than when something
goes wrong think about what you could do
think about what you would do if you had
the puncture how you deal with it
depends on how prepared you are and we
could draw an analogy with the cold warm
and hot patterns so if you're driving
along you have a puncture but you have
no spare tire so you need to call
someone out to come out to you with the
replacement tire and then they have to
fit one you have to wait until they
arrive moving along the continuum the
equivalent of a warm pattern would be if
you had to spare
okay so yeah you do have to stop but you
can fit the kit you can fit the tire or
fix fix the tire or can replace it and
then you're on your journey so you've
had a bit of a break but if you have a
run flat tire
yeah you need to slow down but this you
don't stop there's no real impact on
your journey okay so it's just basically
the idea of how ready you are and
therefore how quickly you can recover so
let's look at a few examples of how you
can apply these patterns to production
workloads on GCP this cold pattern
example requires you only ever have a
single instance so it's the instance up
and running here the serving instance is
part of the instance group and that
group is used the backend service for an
HTTP load balancer the heartbeat in
snapshot instance is part of a managed
instance group managed instance groups
are a group of identical instances which
work with load balance and services to
distribute network traffic to all of the
instances in the group the manage
distance group is controlled by GCE
autoscaler the autoscaler is confited to
keep exactly one running one instance
running at all times if it fails then
another identically configured instance
is launched in its place the heartbeat
in snapshot instance runs a cron job at
regular intervals to snapshot the
serving incidents and it also checks the
health of the serving incidents at
regular intervals
if the heartbeat and snapshot instance
detects that the serving instance has
been unresponsive for specified period
of time
it instantiates a new serving instance
using the latest snapshot and that's the
new instance to the manager instance it
managed instance group when the new
serving instance comes online the HTTP
load balancer begins to dive direct your
traffic to the new instance looking at
this warm statics example you can see
how we can make we're making use of
cloud storage to provide a dr solution
for a web app running on compute engine
in the unlikely event that you are
unable to serve your application from
compute engine instances then you can
mitigate service interruption but
in a cloud storage bays static site on
standby in the normal configuration
cloud DNS is configured to point at this
primary application and the standby
static site sits doorman in the event
that the compute engine application is
unable to serve due to a problem you
would simply configure cloud doing this
the point of the static site this
implementation of a warm pattern is one
of those patterns where the cloud has
encouraged you to think differently if
you do not need all those Wiggly moving
parts all the time this could be the
pattern for you a hot pattern when your
productions on GCP is basically a well
architected H a deployment in this
example we're making use of a regional
manager instance group together with
load balancing in cloud sequel as I
mentioned earlier manage the instance
groups are groups of identical instances
which work with load balancing services
to distribute network traffic to all of
the instances in the group in this
example we are using a regional managed
instance group so we have instances that
are distributed across three zones now
what's really cool about regional
management into the group is that you
get a change in depth it provides
mechanisms to react to failures at the
application incidents or zone level and
you don't have to manually intervene if
any of those scenarios should occur to
address application level recovery as
part as part setting up the managed
instance group HTTP health checks are
configured that monitor and verify that
services are running properly on the
instances in that group if a health
check determines that a service has
failed or failed on an instance the
group automatically recreates the
instance moving up the stack if an
instance in the group unexpectedly stops
crash is always deleted the managed
instance group is all automatically
recreates the instance they can resume
its processing tasks and if for some
reason the zone becomes available you do
not have to intervene as by using a
Regional Manager instance group they
will still be it's instances available
to serve in your application the global
load balancer accepts traffic through a
single global external
IP address and then distributes traffic
according to forwarding rules you define
you set up health checks here to sure
that new connections are only
load-balanced to health the instance
that up and ready to receive them in the
data layer we have cloud sequel which is
configured for hey CheY so we have set
up a failover replica in a different
zone from the master all changes made to
the data on the master including to user
tables are replicated to the failover
replicas uses semi asynchronous
replication if the zone where the master
is located experiences an outage cloud
sequel automatically fails over to the
replicas and your data continues to be
available to clients existing
connections to the instance are closed
but your application can reconnect using
the same connection string or IP address
as you don't need to update your
application after failover
after the failover the replica becomes
the master and cloud sequel
automatically creates a new failover
replica in another zone this
architecture is a great example of why
by using services that provide hey CheY
facilities your application can
automatically recover when things go
wrong ok my favorite tool is dr toolbox
is deployment manager it allows you to
define what your environment should look
like using ginger templates and python
with the flute few clicks or a single
cue g-cloud command you can bring up an
environment within minutes
let's see deployment manager in action
bringing up the h a web application we
just looked at I'd like to welcome Oleg
Oleg one of my colleagues based out of
our Amsterdam office is going to drive
the demo for us Oleg thanks that's
wizard by the way he's our office dog
and he's human I did pay him by the way
I gave him dog treats for let me use his
picture ok so the first thing Oleg is
going to do is download a set of
deployment management templates
from a bucket and he's going to deploy
it using the g-cloud tool
so deployment manager uses a set of
decorative templates to let you constant
consistently deploy update and delete
resources such as GCE gke and cloud
storage for example typically you will
have a minimum a configuration file and
one or more template files schema files
are usually or are also usually part of
the parcel they allow you to declare a
set of rules and configurations in a set
of rules a configuration file must meet
if it wants to use a particular template
okay so templates as I mentioned can be
written in ginger or Python your choice
ginger is simpler but less powerful than
using Python using Python gives you the
ability to programmatically generate the
contents of your templates you could
pass variables to your templates which
make them easy to use we set up the
cloud sequel back-end up earlier because
in reality you're not likely to recreate
your database environments crach in a dr
Sarat scenario so we didn't either okay
bearing in mind if you don't have a
database already up and running not only
would you need to create the database if
you don't have to load it with data and
it would affect how long it takes to
recover and that's what RTO value you
have it wouldn't be a small value in any
dr pattern that involves a database of
some car of some kind that tends to be
the overarching recovery process that
dictates the achievable RTO right so can
we look at the autoscaler templates it
is so we don't need to gather around his
laptop that's good okay so if you look
at this template file you'll see that
we've declared the minimum number of
electric loads that the autoscaler can
scale down to is 3 we can switch to can
you switch to the GC a console please
yes ok so remember we said three so you
can see we've got three instances there
all right can you delete one of them now
instance and Olek go nuts
as we have auto-scaling on it will
automate automatically replace the
instance that Oleg is just deleted I
spoke earlier about hey che in depth
using managed instance groups together
with auto scaling of groups being a key
tool okay so here we demonstrate this
capability at the instance failure let
level but equally we could set up a HTTP
health check that we set up against the
group if that detects that the actual
application one of the instance failed
it would automatically create a new
instance and delete the failing one okay
if you're using thanks so like if you're
using a load balancer as well you can
also set up health checks here - but
load balancer health steps will just
stop serving traffic they don't actually
remove the instance they don't delete
them okay so you need to understand how
to set out both types of health checks
the rule of thumb is have been more
conservative with setting up health
checks against the managed instance
group okay so as you can see the third
the the replacement instance is coming
up as there isn't a case we got there in
the end sorry about the delay as there
isn't actually anything wrong with a
zone the replacement instance got
launched into the same zone is the one
we were deleted so anyone was paying
attention and though it's the zone you
would see its put it straight back into
the same on all right we can easily tear
so after that we can easily tear down
the deployment by just deleting it so
okay so this is great if you're doing
test rests of those two dr environment
which you should do you know so i
understand having been there myself is
the fact that doing full-scale tests are
difficult this just makes life easier
you know you've seen it you fired up at
the environment we pulled it down as
well so you're not actually happy to
invent investing lots of stuff that's
staying there you don't use very often
and then you're worried because you
don't use it very often why hasn't it
come up you know
so moving on okay okay
thank you very much charlie thank you
thanks oleg okay so moving on this look
at dr when production is on premises and
your recovery
I is cloud platform so I'll be covering
when your production is just in GCP when
your user GCP is the recovery site for
your on-premises and were closed there
are a few key things you need to
consider the initial question usually
been how do you connect to GCP GCP
provides a number of ways to connect for
on-premises cloud internet being the
ideal way to provide a consistent
reliable Ning link you need to take into
consideration factors such as the
bandwidth between you and the carrier
interconnect provider as well as the
actual bandwidth provided by the
provider directly to GCP think about
what other data we'll be using that link
it's either how much data has been
transferred and how long have you got to
me any RTO values you can see from this
table by what by the way which isn't
taken into account any external factors
at all that bandwidth availability does
have a direct effect on the time it
takes to transfer data don't forget to
take into account your security controls
you may determine that you want total
control of encryption keys it's a factor
in the end-to-end encryption decryption
process who would have access think
about authentication and authorization
mechanisms how much can you automate
remember everything is an API so you
don't need to rely on an actual probably
just sleepy human to start bringing up
online your dr site I know whenever I
had to do it to get a dr and tsunami it
was always in the middle of the night I
was always half asleep so when taking a
traditional approach to dr on-premises
it typically involved somewhere in the
process people drive in vans and
swapping tapes around the tapes usually
or should I say hopefully being the
off-site backup remember remember this
well we can use the same tiered storage
approach to replace the need for tapes
and fans moving tapes on and off-site we
can replace the source to be your
on-premises storage appliance for
example so here you need to set up
connectivity to GCP as in this so in
this example
we are using GCPs cloud interconnect
service you can then implement a process
to copy data from the storage device to
a slice the cloud storage bucket this
process can be very simple usually say
the GSU to command you may also want to
set up a GCS lifecycle rule like we
described before to delete data and move
to a cheaper storage class here's an
example of a cold pattern in this
example we have practically nothing
running in your target GCP project when
there's a problem that prevents the
production environment running
production workloads you deploy a
deployment manager template to create an
environment capable of running
production workloads know that we were
trickling data into cloud storage as
part of that production environment
you'll need to implement processes to
restore the applications to all the
instances is spun up so think back to
the continuum of images we spoke about
earlier you'd also need to think of a
way to transfer data from cloud storage
in the database you spin up in GCP when
you invoke your dr plan and start
serving production traffic from your GC
and GC p environment this pattern may be
the most cost-effective but it has the
highest IPO in RTO values of the
patterns and requires the most
operational effort to recover from
moving on here's what a warm is standby
setup could look like here we have a
multi-tiered application running on
premises while using a minimal recovery
suite on GC p ignore the cloud sequel
instance for a moment I'll come back to
that you could see that a database
service server instance is running on
the GCP side the instance must run at
all time so that it can receive
replicated transactions via asynchronous
or semi asynchronous replication
techniques to reduce costs you can run
the database on the smallish machine
type capable of running the database
service as this will be a long-running
instance sustained use discounts will
apply when the on-premises application
needs to failover you can make the date
based system on GC p production ready
by destroying the small database
instance making sure to keep the
persistent disk containing your database
system intact if your system is on the
boot disk you only set the auto delete
state of the disk to force bits before
destroying the instance create a new
instance using the Machine type that has
appropriate resources for handling a
production load and attach the
persistent disk containing your database
system to the new instance in the event
of disaster the monitoring service will
be triggered to spin up the web tier and
application tier instances in GCP you
can then adjust the cloud DNS record to
point the web tier which in this example
point to the external IP address of the
HTTP load balancing server service okay
so coming back to that cloud sequel
instance if your on-premises database is
my sequel you can use a cloud sequel
replica instead of the VM instance and
data is replicated directly from the
external master to the cloud sequel
replicas for smaller RTO values you
could adjust the above strategy by
keeping all of the compute engine
instances operational but not receiving
traffic this is not cost-effective but
may be an option that meets your needs
you may want a ready to take over
production workload database instance so
you can omit the resizing of your
instance in this pattern you'll notice
that you have to replicate the data to
your database this is one way of
ensuring your dr failover database is
kept up to date there are other options
for keeping you recovery day base
up-to-date the methods you choose will
have a direct impact on your RPO value
you may choose to apply backup and
transactional logs as your daily
recovery strategy this means you do need
to keep copies of the transaction log
files as well as the backups you need to
regularly restore backups and apply
transaction log files to your recovery
database and test that it acts just like
the production database exactly how you
implement this depends on the flavor of
database you're using maybe you have a
read copy that could promote can be
promoted similar to the techniques we
discussed when using H a cloud sequel
you could choose to keep a copy of the
raw data on cloud storage and rebuild
them assuming your RTO was
long enough to allow that what happens
when you've fallen over to your dr
database how do you then get your
production database that back up to date
in many cases it's just the reverse
process you've been following to keep
your dr database up to date data
recovery is tricky and you need to run
regular fire drills and be totally
confident that you can happily run
production whether you are using your
production database your dr database
take advantage of cloud to plot your
deployment manager to spin up your
failover application point it out your
dr database to validate and once you're
done you can take down your replica
environment down until it's needed for
the next fire drill if you have very
small RTO and RPO values that you could
take that warm pattern and modify it so
it's just at a check across with GCP
which gives you a hot pattern as both
on-premises and GC p are served in
production traffic the key differences
from the previous pattern being that
everything is running in production mode
and serving production traffic the GCE
instances are part of a managed instance
group behind a load balancer and the GCP
database instance instance is production
ready if you do choose to implement this
type of hybrid approach be sure to
consider a DNS server service that
supports weighted routing when routing
traffic to the production to the two
production environments so you're able
to deliver the same application from
both in the event that what an
environment becomes available you can
then deal disable the DNS routine took
from took from the unavailable
environment so we've discussed several
examples of using production workloads
and GCP and on-premises I'm just going
to discuss briefly now what techniques
you can adopt when you're running
production across clouds if your
application involves virtual machines
running across different clouds again
you have to figure out where on the
continuum your images are for both
clouds you want to use tooling that
works across them both if it's a fully
configured image required consider
something like Packer
which could create identical
machine images for multiple platforms
from a single configuration file you can
use something like terraform which you
know it's a cloud neutral template in
tool okay so you know so you might want
to if you're just just running on GCP
you use the native tools if you're
running across clouds you need to find
something that runs across both of them
you can use configuration management
tool such as chef puppet and support
stack to configure your instances or
even to configure the instances that you
will use to create the images you will
be using that's a very common technique
and it keeps everything consistent if
you if you need to you can set up a VPN
between clouds if you're using
containers you know I'm going to say
there's only one thing to know that he's
saying it's kubernetes with kubernetes
you Confederate across clouds you can
use gke which is some cloud platforms
fully managed kubernetes environment and
then on say as your AWS you can use
kubernetes on there okay there are other
techniques and solutions to the ones
I've just discussed that you can
implement for multiple cloud scenario
scenarios for example if you want to
replicate data from AWS s3 to cloud
storage then you can do this easily as
well maybe by using boto which is a
Python tool designed to work with AWS
which also supports cloud storage
there's plenty of ways to do this it's
not going to be easy I'm not going to
I'm not going to deny it but you can do
this okay so just to recap why using GCP
is the destination you should be
thinking of for your dr needs it
improves your TCO it's easy to carry out
the fire drill so you and have a greater
degree of confidence that in the
unfortunate situation you have a
disaster then like wizard here your ops
team will be calmly executing the
recovery process also you don't need to
keep rethinking patterns they apply no
matter where your production workload is
running
so there you have it if you're thinking
of dr either to revamp your current
solution or wanting to actually
implement a new dr solution
hopefully we're giving you plenty of
ideas
[Music]
[Music]